British airports are warning of
Passenger delays as security staff walk
off the job today
the thousands of UK workers are now
staging multiple strikes as the cost of
living crisis and the lack of workers in
the public sector continue to bite
nurses ambulance staff Highway workers
Rail and postal workers even Customs
officials and bus drivers are all
striking this week alone
it's being referred to as the winter of
discontent workers want pay increases to
match Rising prices but that's a demand
that Westminster so far isn't prepared
to meet it's the country's biggest wave
of strikes in decades
Hillary Ingram is an economist at
Lancaster University and she joins me
now for more Hillary good to have you on
the show
um most Brits right now or it seems like
many Brits are experiencing this sudden
crunch in their real wages as prices
rise do they have support from what you
see or do they support I should say what
they're seeing from these striking
workers because of that because they
know the pain themselves
well everybody is affected by this cost
of living crisis you know it's not just
the UK either but in the UK you know
we've got inflation and double digits
just the other side of 10 and yet the
pay increases people are being afforded
you know are five percent or less so on
average the nurses I think I've got 4.75
now in terms of what the public feel if
you actually look at the nurses strike
they are actually very supportive of
them because of course these are a group
of people that worked all the way
through the pandemic many actually lost
their lives
um we know there are shortages that
they're overworked and there's about
two-thirds of the public actually
support them that is not true for all
the other groups that are walking out
Hillary you just touched on this cost of
living right now is a crisis not just in
the UK but across much of Europe to what
extent is what we're seeing in the UK
though to what extent does it have its
own distinct elements that are separate
from what we're seeing in Europe
well I mean I think the the overall
influence is a very similar I mean a lot
of this inflation it's sort of global
it's caused by the energy markets and
everybody is suffering but we don't seem
in the UK to be able to come to some
agreement between government and you
know public sector workers over what pay
is actually affordable or that what the
government is willing to advance and it
seems that you know particularly with
the nurses the health secretaries being
quite in transient he said he's willing
to negotiate over conditions but there's
no indication that he's going to
negotiate over significant pay increases
I mean what we read in the papers today
is that he might be willing to bring
next year's pay increase forward uh now
whether that will be acceptable to the
nurses Union is another matter
critics say that recent governments have
not invested enough in the Health Care
system in the UK and in general in
infrastructure do you subscribe to that
view as well
I think if you look at look at the money
that's gone into the NHS I mean vast
amounts of money have gone into the NHS
but it doesn't seem to deliver what
people want
um even before these strikes you know
we've had Tales of waiting lists have
been getting longer and longer and
longer you know you have to wait hours
and hours for an ambulance and then
sometimes ambulance is occurring for
like 12 hours to actually discharge
patients I get them actually admitted
into a hospital so they can go out on
their next job so I think you need to
look at the overall system here and I
mean one of the things that people have
said for many many years is that there's
no actual link between Health and Social
care so the problem is you've got people
actually blocking up hospital beds
um that could be discharged into a sort
of residential setting either going back
home or in a care home but but that is
not happening so I think you need to
look at the Whole Health and Social care
package uh not just at one element of it
Hillary Ingham at Lancaster University
thank you very much
thank you